bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour une
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction de tv fil 78 dans l'actualité
de ce 2 mars 2015 la décision du conseil
d'état d'annuler le scrutin municipal à
voisins le bretonneux un an après pose
quelques soucis à la majorité de
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise nous
verrons les conséquences de ce
chamboulement politique elle les anciens
dirigeants de promo paul pépinière
d'entreprises basées à montigny le
bretonneux mais aussi à trappes assigné
devant le tribunal de commerce de
nanterre un audit révèle plusieurs
dysfonctionnements nous en parlerons
avec l'actuel président de la structure
othman nasu et puis elle les chasseurs
rangent leurs fusils la saison est
maintenant terminée et ce week-end pour
la clôture c'est une animation
pédagogique que ces derniers ont
organisé vous le verrez politique le
front national en tête des intentions de
vote à trois semaines des élections
départementales 33% des français
seraient prêts à glisser dans l'urne le
22 mars pour le premier tour un bulletin
aux couleurs de la formation de marine
le pen selon un sondage doxa le parisien
est diffusé ce matin elle recueillerait
même le vote d'un jeune sur deux de 25 à
34 ans le fn qu'il devance l'ump lui dei
avec 27% et le ps à 19% le fn qui creuse
donc l'écart ce scrutin qui immobilise
si peu d'une majeure à une manière
générale devrait donc avoir de lourdes
conséquences sur le paysage politique
alors qu'à la fin de l'année ce sont
vous le savez les élections régionales
qui seront organisées et vous
seriez-vous prêt à voter pour le front
national le rassemblement bleu marine
nous sommes allés vous posez la question
dans les rues de saint quentin ont livré
une micro trottoir signé patrick jacques
de dixmude et william a non pas le front
national surtout pas le jour national
non question de conviction voilà tout
simplement n'ont jamais été front
national sauf que il ya quelque chose de
kim dérange qu'est violent qui est je
suis plus quelqu'un qui va moduler les
choses et le front national est trop
extrémiste pour moi oui oui sans
problème
pour quelle raison parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'offre politique correspond plus du
tout ce qu'on peut espérer que ce soit à
droite ou à gauche
donc pourquoi pas changé et voir un
petit peu ce que 2e sont capables de
faire ah non pas du tout parce que nous
sommes engagés dans un autre parti
pourquoi pas parce que c'est un parti
comme un autre
non parce que je ne partage pas leur
point de vue verdict donc à la à l'issue
de ce mois à le 22 mars premier tour des
élections départementales politique
toujours de nouvelles élections à
voisins le bretonneux et c'est
l'organisation communautaire de la casse
qui qui se trouve entièrement modifié le
vote du budget est prévu le 15 avril
il pourrait être repoussé les
explications avec catherine château la
vie de voisins-le-bretonneux n'a plus de
conseil municipal et l'agglomération
saint quentinois se retrouve amputée de
quatre de ses élus communautaires
ce qui change la couleur politique de
l'assemblée le conseil communautaire de
la casse qui se sont en effet 48
délégués représentant les sept communes
en termes d' équilibre politique 25 élus
sont à ce jour de droite et 23 sont de
gauche avec la démission des quatre élus
communautaires à droite de
voisins-le-bretonneux l'assemblée donc
mathématiquement à gauche
l'exécutif avait prévu de voter le 15
avril le budget primitif 2015
un report pourrait être demandé
j'attends déjà de connaître la date des
élections veut officiels qui seront
fixés par le préfet des yvelines et
ensuite eh bien on regardera en fonction
des dates précises s'il faut que l'on
bouge de quelques jours je demanderai au
préfet l'autorisation de pouvoir bouger
de quelques jours le vote du budget je
pense que je peux bien comprendre ça
parton moment où il ya une élection
annulée mais il faut attendre que le
conseil d'agglo soit au complet surtout
pour voter un budget donc aujourd'hui il
n'y a rien qui bloque le fonctionnement
de la communauté de l'agglomération de
la seule chose aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
arrêtée c'est le vote définitif du
budget pour l'année 2015
une situation inédite une fois les
élections passées à moins d'un rapport
de force politique inversée à voisins le
bretonneux
ce qui n'est jamais arrivé la droite
devrait redevenir majoritaire reste à
connaître la date de cette municipale
partielle
certains avancent déjà la mi avril la
justice va devoir se prononcer sur le
dossier promo paul la pépinière
d'entreprise fondée en 1987 afin d'aider
les pme les pmi est en grande difficulté
financière les dettes s'accumulent pour
cette société d'économie mixte mise en
place à l'époque par les élus de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines une situation qui a poussé la
nouvelle majorité de droite de la casse
qui a commandé un audit est aujourd'hui
emmanuel lafont l'ancien directeur et
jean yves gendron l'ex-président sont
suspectés je cite à d'avoir exploité une
situation de vulnérabilité tout en
mélangeant les genres des propos tenus
par othman nasro conseiller municipal
d'opposition à trappes et président de
promo paul depuis juin est dernier des
propos rapportés dans le parisien
bonsoir othman nasri qu'est ce qui vous
permet aujourd'hui d'être aussi
affirmatif dans ses accusations douter
c'est extrêmement clair quand on
récupère une situation qui effectivement
comme vous l'avez rappelé très dégradée
sur le plan financier on regarde les
éléments vous avez parlé d'un audit
indépendant qui a été fait et puis on
constate un fait assez simple
en l'occurrence c'est que la société et
du directeur du protocole facturer un
certain nombre de prestations de
services pour des montants assez
important à promo parce qu'il était à la
fois le président de promo paul et en
même temps directeur de l'union par les
directeurs promo paul en même temps
président du nom de structure tout à
fait qu'il facture est stable évidemment
cela s'appelle un conflit d'intérêt
alors par rapport à salon n'a pas eu
d'autre choix que de prendre nos
responsabilités et d'engager une
procédure en justice pour réclamer le
remboursement de ces sommes parce qu'on
parle de 40000 euros qui ont été
effectivement facturé alors que
provoquait elle était déjà dans une
situation de quasi faillite ne pouvait
pas régler ces échéances bancaires et
donc évidemment c'est un mélange des
genres qui interroge maintenant il
appartient à la justice naturellement de
dire ce qu'il en est
simplement on ne peut pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis ou donné quitus
à une gestion qui a coûté autant
d'argent aux contribuables
sur quelle période ça s'est déroulé ce
préjudice que c'est comme ça que vous
l'estimez de quelques quarante mille 40
de 1000 euros principalement au
lendemain des élections municipales
c'est à dire sur la période de
transition juste avant que je prenne mes
fonctions en juin dernier au moment où
j'ai été nommé à la présidence résidence
est effectivement lié pour le rappeler
pour les téléspectateurs à la à la
majorité de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines qui détermine
ensuite la présidence des différentes
structures qui gravitent autour dont
promo paul bien évidemment tout à fait
donc quand j'ai pris mes fonctions j'ai
découvert une situation qui a été
extrêmement compliqué une société qui ne
faisait plus face à ses échéances depuis
plusieurs mois et puis cette situation
de conflit d'intérêts qui
malheureusement rappeler d'autres actes
de gestion les qui jure on pouvait
constater dans la gestion de propofol
et c'est une gestion qui de mon point de
vue n'est plus acceptable promo pas là
malheureusement on l'outil des sommes
considérables dans une gestion largement
critiquable s'agit de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros et je
crois que maintenant il faut mettre un
terme définitif à ce gâchis d'argent
public qui malheureusement aurait dû
s'arrêter bien avant mais vous avez eu
des échanges avec une ancienne direction
pour demander des explications sur ses
facturations parce que c'est la justice
vous l'avez dit qu'il va devoir se
prononcer ses factures ont été établies
si pour l'instant on peut se baser sur
sur le fait que les prestations ont été
honorés la justice tranchera ensuite
donc est-ce que vous avez ne serait ce
qui est échangé avec l'ancienne
direction pour essayer d'y voir plus
clair sur ces dossiers sur ses factures
naturellement j'ai demandé un certain
nombre d'éléments de réponse pour
essayer de comprendre la situation pour
l'évaluer c'est pour cela qu'on en parle
que maintenant il ya aussi le temps
judiciaire le but n'est pas de faire les
choses dans l'urgence de régler des
comptes
simplement au bout d'un moment il faut
en son âme et conscience prendre ses
responsabilités et il était évident que
ce qui avait été fait dans cette gestion
là ne pouvait pas être de la gestion
normale classique traditionnelle en bon
père de famille on a affaire surprenant
paul je lui ai déjà dit à des fautes de
gestion manifeste des erreurs
stratégiques lourde et normalement
naturellement dans n'importe quelle
structure la question des
responsabilités se pose et en
particulier dans une structure qui est
quand même une structure d'économie
mixte vous là vient rappeler c'est à
dire où il ya de l'argent public donc
dans ce cas précis il faut absolument
que les responsabilités soient établies
et on n'a pas d'autre choix on parle
quand même réussi de deux montants assez
important qui nous sont aussi l'argent
des entreprises de broc paul la dette
on vient
deux millions deux millions six d'euros
sur cette structure aux promos paul au
delà de ce dossier de 40000 euros qu'on
évoquait il ya quelques instants
vous avez réussi à assainir un peu les
finances ces derniers mois oui or la
bonne nouvelle parce qu'il y en a aussi
dans cette affaire c'est que la gestion
la stratégie qu'on a mises en place lors
de l'alternance que vous avez évoqué
porte ses fruits
on a aujourd'hui une gestion extrêmement
rigoureuse on a économisé 150000 euros
qui ont permis à provo paul d'assurer la
pérennité de son service de son offre de
services il n'y a pas une seule
entreprise qui a été pénalisé dans cette
crise alors que effectivement on a
récolté une situation absolument
dramatique
aujourd'hui on l'espère bientôt en voir
le bout j'espère revenir vous voir avec
des nouvelles positives voir enfin le
bout du tunnel donc on est encore en
train de tout remettre à plat
c'est un séduisant pour les entreprises
qui veulent venir s'installer dans le
cadre de promo paul pascon le rappelle
il ya des services qui sont proposés
il ya des locaux qui sont passés à
disposition à des tarifs plus
intéressants pour les entreprises qui se
lancent bien évidemment les entreprises
encore aujourd'hui vous sollicite pour
venir s'installer dans vos locaux
oui naturellement alors il y avait un
problème d'attractivité aussi de l'image
de marque de promo paul qui ne s'est pas
forcément réformer au fil des ans et si
vous voulez on a affaire aux
conséquences aussi d'une gestion qui
n'était pas une gestion du chef
d'entreprise donc aujourd'hui on l'a
remis les choses à plat en train de tout
remettre à plat le commercial
l'attractivité du bâtiment de montigny
l'offre de valeur qu'on propose aux
entreprises ce travail bien sûr prend du
temps on essaye néanmoins d'aller vite
en six mois je pense qu'on a fait
beaucoup de chemin et donc j'ai bien
l'intention de redonner un second
souffle une seconde jeunesse avec
l'appui de la nouvelle majorité
communautaire à cet outil qu'est promo
paul qui doit remplir encore plus ses
ambitions pour le développement
économique du territoire
vous parlez du site de montigny le
bretonneux juste pour conclure l'avenir
de ses différents sites celui de
montigny est à part parce que celui de
travel gérer maintenant par la
municipalité
c'est comme ça que ça doit fonctionner
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
négociation avec la ville de trappes il
est effectivement question de ce
scénario où la ville de trappes
reprendre et les sites des merisiers de
torres de propofol ont été négociés sur
n'est pas encore aboutie j'espère que
effectivement ce serait plutôt ce
scénario qui sera retenu parce que
propose n'a pas aujourd'hui les moyens
de continuer à investir sur sur les
sites de trappes qui ont été dans
l'exploitation était très déséquilibré
dans le montage qui a été pensée avec la
ville de trappes donc cette négociation
est en cours et bien sûr et les sans
lien je tiens à le préciser avec la
question
des responsabilités quant à lui aussi
sur sur sur la place publique mais il
faut que chacun s'explique y compris la
précédente majorité
mais ça c'était un autre sujet qui
j'espère n'impactera pas le futur
développement de protocoles et sa
relance ce sera l'occasion de revenir en
plateau merci antoine masson président
de promo paul à saint quentin en
yvelines
on va changer de sujet pour poursuivre
ce journal à présent la saison de la
chasse au grand gibier est maintenant
terminée depuis samedi à cette occasion
le club des jeunes chasseurs d'île de
france a invité ses adhérents à une
matinée pédagogique autour de la
réglementation c'était dans la commune
de bonnel avec des projections de films
des explications et des démonstrations
sur le terrain pour expliquer en quoi
était nécessaire la chasse williams elle
pour ce reportage
là encore absolument pas de battue ce
matin pour ces jeunes chasseurs les plus
tôt un retour à l'école le club des
jeunes chasseurs d'île de france a
organisé une journée pédagogique pour
ses adhérents l'occasion de parfaire ses
connaissances sur le grand gibier
la gratification en gb commence chez
nous
au chevreuil en passant par saint imier
et serbie on se retrouve
actuellement une activité qui est quand
même un bel essai il faut penser à
l'avenir et je pense que jones a surfé
dernière un avenir qu'il faut préparer
dès maintenant mais surtout encadrer les
techniques de chasse et les règles de
sécurité sont expliqués minutieusement
par des intervenants professionnels il
ya prés déconne on est chasseur soit de
de père en fils ou on a beaucoup de
parisiens qui viennent à la chasse parce
que ils veulent décompresser de
de la semaine de boulot ces gens là ont
tout à apprendre 12 but de cette matinée
aussi aidés des formations qui sont
faits tout au long de l'année par les
différentes associations cynégétiques
l'après midi exercice pratique une
recherche au sang avec un chien de rouge
une méthode désormais obligatoire nos
chiens sont spécialisés pour rechercher
ces animaux blessés et qui doit faire la
différence entre les animaux sains et la
voix de l'animal blessé sur les 25000
chasseurs d'ile-de-france 5000 aurait
moins de 27 ans et serait donc de jeunes
chasseurs l'association elle ne compte
qu'une centaine d'adhérents bien trop
faible un mot de ce sport en rugby le
club de versailles s'impose face à
lagrange d'armentières et conservez donc
une chance d'accéder aux phases finales
du championnat de france ce sera bien
évidemment l'un des titres du 7-8 sport
avec mickaël mille euros 7,8 sport a
retrouvé tout au long de ce lundi soir
sur notre antenne demain pour le journal
catherine zola tôt ce sera pour la
première diffusion en direct à 18h et
moi je vous retrouverai à partir de
18h30 pour le 7-8 politique et 19h
premier débat dans le cadre des
départementales très bonne soirée